hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up in the next 10 minutes
chronically underfunded and overlooked a
new report from the UK's climate change
Watchdog warns that the UK is under
spending on climate change adaptation
a Giant Mountain of sludge full of dead
animals and plastic bottles is being
removed from a lake in Serbia
environmentally say it's not on
and climbing back from the brink of
Extinction researchers say the
population of Western monarch
butterflies in California has risen for
the second year in a row
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now the UK's climate Watchdog has
warned the government that they've been
too slow in addressing the challenges of
climate change and will need to invest
billions of pounds to prepare for the
impacts of a warming climate
now the independent climate change
committee says 10 billion pounds a year
will be required as part of a major
program of investment to prepare the UK
for the impacts of climate change
it says the country must prepare for
flooding proofing houses and
infrastructure against its impacts
well investment will also have to be
made to protect the public water supply
in nature restoration well our Science
and Technology editor Tom Clarke joins
me now Tom thanks so much for joining us
lots to unpick there but the government
essentially being accused of acting slow
and if they do there's a hefty bill each
year for them
that's right and the longer they
continue to act slowly the bigger that
Bill gets effectively because the bigger
the threat of the risks associated with
the warming that we're already going to
have because of the emissions we put
into the atmosphere that's things that
you were saying like heat waves extreme
rainfall events that cause flooding the
droughts we saw last summer that
affected both Agriculture and domestic
water supplies and those things need to
be addressed big spending on
infrastructure on flood defenses on
buildings that the government has to
tackle now the report said there's a
clear plan from government when it comes
to cutting our carbon of dioxide
emissions through their Net Zero
strategy even though there's still
things lacking in terms of implementing
that at least there's a clear direction
of travel they're saying in this report
there just isn't that same level of
Engagement or planning to do the
adaptation piece how are we going to
cope with the warming we've already got
and there are some big sort of ticket
items on here let me just rattle a few
the report identifiers about a billion a
year we need to carry on spending on
flood defense that that's every year
point seven billion to improve the
public water supply make it more
resilient those drought events we talk
about and those stormy events when
sewage gets discharged into rivers about
a billion a year to retrofit housing to
make it better insulation against heat
as well as staying warm in the winter we
need to protect against heat waves
office of national statistics by the way
estimated a few weeks ago that maybe up
to 3 000 people died due to the summer
heat wave we recently had an
infrastructure as a whole this is not
Railways New Roads Bridges
650 billion pounds by 2030 some really
expensive items there
okay Tom Clark thank you very much for
that
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news for you now and
construction machines are being
repurposed to clear tons of waste
clogging the poppeck lake in Southwest
Serbia now the problem spans decade and
stems from a lack of Environmental
Protection over Riverside landfills and
take a look at this 10
000 cubic meters of waste has been
pulled from the river in the last year
environmental activists say tough action
is needed now on people and companies
dumping waste in the lake which is
against the law
well new research has shown that
planting more trees could reduce the
number of deaths during heat waves a
European study found that planting trees
can lower temperatures in cities by
almost half a degree in the summer by
preventing human-made surfaces from
heating up now the Barcelona Institute
for Global Health said a third of heaped
related premature deaths could have been
prevented by more tree cover
now the United States Environmental
Protection Agency has effectively vetoed
a proposed open pit copper and gold mine
in Southwest Alaska now
environmentalists and locals say the
mine would have jeopardized the Region's
salmon fishery which brings thousands of
jobs to the area and they say the
proposed mine site would result in a
loss of nearly 100 miles of stream
habitat as well as Wetland areas the
mining company has maintained the
project can co-exist with the salmon
industry
researchers say that the population of
butterflies wintering along the
California coast has rebounded for a
second year in a row volunteers counted
more than 330 000 butterflies the
highest number of these insects counted
in the last six years but they warn that
the population is still well below what
it used to be and this is from the
effects of climate change pesticides and
the destruction of their habitat I think
we can all celebrate and this is really
exciting we were all so relieved last
year when we hit about 250 000
butterflies so to see that number tick
up even more a little bit modestly this
year is really a good sign so we know we
still have a long ways to go for
Recovery we still estimate that we're
down over 90 percent from those historic
Norms so that shifting baselines I think
is really important like this is great
compared to three years ago this is not
great compared to three decades ago
and before we go we want your climate
questions anything that's ever mystified
you about the environment or whatever
you want to get to the bottom of scan
the QR code on the screen right now send
us your questions which will be answered
in the climate Show with Tom Heap
and you'll be able to watch Tom's show
on Saturday and Sunday at 3 30 here on
Sky News
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to this
week's edition of climate cast you can
listen And subscribe now wherever you
get your podcasts from
well thanks for watching that's all from
us today join us again on the daily
climate show at 3 30 tomorrow bye
[Music]